this is the probe Nick nestled against
the Adriatic it's easy to see why this
city has been a hit with TV crews and
tourists the protected medieval town
features in the last series of the smash
hit game of thrones no Ajami foul and
now locals are looking to cash in extras
have been coming from all over the
region sometimes even from farther away
as a big fans they wanted to be part of
the project Ivanovic runs a game of
thrones walking to a charging $75 she
draws crowds from across the globe a lot
of people from Australia from America
especially younger people who know about
the game of thrones know Dubrovnik to
that series so that sort of introduces
them and they want to come here to see
where it was filmed the broth Nick's
history dates back to the Middle Ages
when it was an important trading hub and
often the target of conquerors more
recently when the former Yugoslavia
broke up in the 90s Dubrovnik was
shelled and damaged by yugoslavia and
Croatia's war for independence now the
city wants to restore its place on the
global tourist map and radish hopes Game
of Thrones will help spread the word
anger Spanish Bloomberg